all right first video of the new year
2021 we're starting it off right
optimism positivity that's where we're
coming from enjoyment cobra kai
say yeah cuppa kai never dies
i want to hear that next season
cobra kai season three so cooper kai
season three is the third season of
cobra kai it's on netflix this is quite
a hiatus it feels like season two came
out
eons so now we finally have season three
and just letting you know spoilers the
spoiler warning here i'm gonna talk
about spoilers for season three
it's not gonna be a play-by-play or
anything like that i'm just gonna get a
little more spoiler-ish than maybe you
would want me to
so you know watch cobra kai's season
three
if you don't want spoilers or don't
watch this video or watch season three
and then come back to this video point
is
long story short season three is good
cobra kai is good you should watch it if
you haven't gotten on it by now you
should
knows the time friends now's the time
that's where we left off in cobra kai
season two
lots of things went down there was a
super high school brawl among
cobra kai and miyagido then robbie
kicked miguel over the stairwell of
their high school miguel
smacked his back on the rail when john
crees steals cobra kai from johnny
johnny's sitting on the beach with that
awesome rendition of cruel summer
playing johnny just
smashes the bottle on his car and leaves
and there's a friend request from allie
mills on facebook
that he didn't know about so yeah people
were in a bad place when season two
ended and they're gonna pick up
pretty much right there though it's been
a couple weeks okay johnny's in a rut
robbie's nowhere to be found miguel is
in a coma john crease is doing pretty
well for himself i mean
he's stole a man's business he's sitting
pretty which i'll i'll start this out by
talking about john crease because john
crease is just
he's just a proper villain the guy is a
complete and total [ __ ] bag i can't
curse in the first
minute of the youtube videos says the
algorithm hopefully it's been a minute
time flies when you're rambling about
cobra kai but he is a complete [ __ ] back
i mean of everybody of cobra kai
karate kid mythos there's that
opportunity to have a turn around you
know we saw
that with sato we've seen it with johnny
there's always that opportunity to turn
it around you know villains can always
become
heroes unless you're john crease that
guy will just die a scumbag because his
arc is pretty much
this in karate kid one he was an
[ __ ] poisoning the minds of youth and
in cobra kai
get this he's an [ __ ] poisoning the
minds of youth
however in this season of cobra kai we
get some backstory with john crease we
see flashbacks of where he came from and
his youth
and when he joined the military and
where that whole mindset
comes from you know that whole mindset
of there's a war
coming rival dojos totally mean war when
we're fighting for the pride and joy of
the san fernando valley
that's just a sane mindset it doesn't
justify it it gives you context without
justifying i just i like seeing the
flashbacks also they have a proper
villain moment otherwise known as just
villain moments where i
like to like the villain for that one
moment they have a moment like that with
john crease the whole enemy of my enemy
thing that's a theme
in this season of cobra kai and it will
be in next season also there's this
moment when tori has
this total creeper landlord who's like
hey you can give you the money
or you can give me something else then
john crease just puts the guy's finger
in a cigar cutter it's pretty much
like you're gonna leave her alone anyhow
good moment i i like a moment where it's
like that guy is irredeemable
complete [ __ ] he will be a [ __ ]
forever
but i did like him in that moment now
miguel and johnny are still the heart of
the show they've been the heart of the
show
from the beginning and they're the heart
of the show now miguel is having a rough
time because
you know he can't walk so johnny's like
i gotta make this right i gotta help him
walk
and i love seeing that though at this
point with cobra kai there are a lot of
cogs man there are a lot of gears
turning there are a lot of factions i
guess you'd say
and at a point in the show i felt like
johnny was kind of getting pushed to the
side like it used to be
johnny's show it was johnny versus
daniel larusso
but daniel was a supporting character
and
they were each other's villains you know
you didn't have this external force you
didn't have this
other villain come into the mix yet so
it was a neat show about villainy and
heroism
and those are perspectives and your
enemy always thinks they're the hero
every villain's the hero of their own
story right right so now daniel's
getting more screen time in this season
i kind of felt like johnny was getting
pushed to the side though it does
the the equation evens out by the end i
also suppose i rolled with it because i
actually
like the arc with daniel where he goes
to japan
and that was a rumor right the whole
rumor online was like oh daniel and
johnny are gonna team up and they're
gonna go to okinawa and it doesn't
really happen
like that daniel and johnny do team up
to go find
robbie but of course you know it's
daniel and johnny so it only lasts so
long and daniel does go to japan
but logistically it's there's a reason
for daniel to go to japan and i
appreciate that i appreciate the fact
that the show's like look
you can't take cobra kai too seriously
it is still a show where dimitri beat
hawk in a fight
impossible but it never fully jumps the
shark to the point where you don't take
the lessons the show's giving you and
yes there are lessons
in this show it never does it to the
point where you don't take those
lessons to heart so enter the fact that
daniel goes to japan it's like well why
would he go to japan
you know maybe he needs to go to japan
to clear his head but
that's like something that someone would
think about but they wouldn't actually
do they'd be like oh i need to go to
okinawa clear my head
but in the end i'll probably just stick
around here and you know the business
needs me so there's a business reason
that he has to go to japan
and while he's at tokyo he's like well
let me go to okinawa and
you know just hop over there it's a
shorter jaunt at that point so why not
yeah when your business is in trouble
you'll get a plane ticket you'll be at
japan
so it actually worked in an interesting
way to get him over there also
when he's catching up with some friends
and
enemy from karate kid 2. i enjoyed
seeing that also
daniel's catching up with camiko chosen
isn't it
you know the one who held kamiko at
knifepoint and said hey we're gonna
fight to the death daniel
or i'm gonna kill her yeah they're all
in a room together now but again it's
it's cobra kai
and the entire theme of the show is the
fact that people
can grow and change it's basically cobra
kai
is the antithesis of social media i
think i've said that before
twitter's twitter cobra kai is a little
more like real life than the fact that
your mistakes of your past
they are yours to own and they
shape you into who you are in the sense
that you grow from them
jean-luc picard can be a cadet who
cheats a nos again at the domjot table
in the name of him getting stabbed and
growing and becoming
jean-luc picard mistakes are supposed to
happen enter the villain from karate kid
2 is now this
really cool wise older dude i thought it
was awesome to see him in that light
when he started to get to where it's
like yeah he
they're probably going to bring karate
kid 2 characters into it you think
how's that gonna go down and i think
making him this
wise friend who's wise because he was a
[ __ ]
in his youth and he's there to give
daniel some wisdom i think that's the
perfect way to have his character in
cobra kai
also ally is in this season there was
also a rumor was like oh ally is going
to perform
the surgery on miguel and help him walk
which doesn't happen that's not how that
happens and i'm glad
because i'd be stuck there going what
are the odds of that i never bought the
idea of ally who
was she live in chicago or something
like that coming
to california to perform surgery on this
kid
because this kid is the student of
someone she dated once in high school it
doesn't happen that way she's in town
because she has
family there and she gets in touch with
johnny because of the facebook message
he sent
last season so it logistically worked
and also
she's not there to be a johnny love
interest because the whole romance thing
with
johnny and miguel's mom that sparks back
up which
go johnny so that sparks back up and you
think oh it's like ally's gonna be who's
gonna be this tension this whole drama
field tension no that kind of love
interest tension
that's for the high school students but
she's here for this
lesson for johnny which is appreciate
who you have now appreciate what you
have now
remember the past enjoy the memories of
the past
but don't live in the past live in the
present live for the future and then
they hug and they go their separate ways
it was it was
the way they brought ali in i thought
was actually pretty smart and again it
points to the fact that cobra kai
it doesn't overcook the camp it doesn't
overcook the cheese
it's a show that's very if i can sum it
up in a word
self-aware that's two words but it's
very self-aware
it knows where it's ridiculous and it
knows how to play up the ridiculousness
but it doesn't make it so ridiculous
that you just
check out it's a solid balance of
ridiculousness
entertainment and heart a balance that
you rarely find these days that's what i
like about it it's kind of
it has enough of the old school mixed
with some flair of the new school
well after all that it does start to get
a bit ridiculous
in the sense that why don't they go to
the cops at the end
like at a point they do try the
larusso's try to go to the cops but john
crease beat them to it was like oh
she came to my dojo and slapped me and
assaulted me all right so he plays that
up i don't know that it would
completely and totally go down like that
but okay i'm glad they at least
addressed the fact of like why don't
they go to the police but at the end
of this season there's this huge throw
down in the larusso household like these
cobra kai's just
break into the larusso house and fight
everybody there
shit's getting destroyed shit's getting
broken people are out for blood
and at the end of this fight when it all
ends daniel goes to john crease he's
like you sent them to my house which of
course fight breaks out which
i i like the fight it's high time that
john crease gets some hits landed on him
i like that fight i actually
i like the fight at the house the cobra
kai end
fights they're always entertaining i
don't think i've liked any of the fights
as much as i like the end
tournament fight from season one though
there's something about
a tournament there are rules there and
there are different logistics than an
all-out brawl
i just enjoy the tactic you need to use
in a tournament because you can't just
go all out i just
i end up being more entertained with a
tournament fight and john crease is like
let's settle this the old-fashioned way
at the tournament i'm like no
i'm calling 9-1-1 because your students
broke into my house
and assaulted people and that's on you
someone would at least
attempt to call the police or report it
but no
the tournament let's do it old school
because we're
fighting for the soul of the valley duh
come on adults but i gotta say as
ridiculous as
that is in particular it does leave off
in a place where i'm really intrigued
for next season you know the whole like
enemy of my enemy thing like i said is
in this show daniel and johnny work
together at a point and actually
there's now three dojos there's miyagi
doe which is daniel
cobra kai which is john crease and
johnny starts his own dojo which is
eagle fang there are some faction
changes like
hawk who is cobra kai for life always
has been
he essentially he flipped and he was
like you know what
i think cobra kai i think they're dicks
now which seemed like a bit of a
sudden flip for me i suppose it felt
sudden for me because it's kind of
said to be like oh the whole breaking
dimitri's arm thing that was the line
for him but really that's not
it is you see that tension between him
and john crease you see him
start to doubt john crease and his
tactics throughout this season john
crease brings in
the bully that called him [ __ ] lip in
the first season
he starts to see that john crease
doesn't care about the kids he just
wants kids to
wage his war for the sake of his own ego
and for the soul of the valley
the important stuff so when i took a
step back and saw it from there i was
like oh okay that's fair that's actually
a thing this show does very
well is it keeps the star villain you
know
like the villain of the season it keeps
that
fresh you never know who it's gonna be
it was most complex for me
first season because it was johnny's kid
in
daniel larusso's dojo miguel
was a cobra kai he was fighting a bit
hardcore but he was a good kid you know
it's like all that complexity working
now it's a little more black and white
it's like
dude john crease and his gang of [ __ ]
bags are clearly the worst
people and we need to stop them for the
soul of the valley
robbie's unlikable i'll be honest he
doesn't have a lot of screen time
but every time he did have screen time i
was like okay this kid again you got a
haircut haircut looks good good
on him because you know he was like guys
producers folks come on they're thiefing
oh god with robbie all right so there's
a scene
you know because high school drama is up
my mom finally saw cobra kai
not too long ago and she just told me
she was like hey i finished cobra kai
as much as you talk so much [ __ ] about
those twilight movies for having that
teen drama [ __ ]
cobra kai has so much of that teen drama
[ __ ] i was like
not the same mom there's a scene where
miguel
and samantha larusso they're in the
backyard you know and they're just like
flirty batty eyes at each other and then
there is robbie
shows up and he's like i see how it is
it's like
yeah robbie i think you see exactly how
it is the kid you kicked off of
the stairwell balcony and paralyzed
is flirting with the girl you never
wrote to when you went to
juvie because of it yeah you probably
see exactly how it is
anyone like if they were in robbie's
position would show up and be like
well in the end i do understand where
they're both coming from on this one
yeah i'm just gonna go ahead and back
out maybe they didn't see me
hopefully the kid's ridiculous but
it does leave off where now he's in
cobra kai and he's training with john
crease
and you know that's a slap in the face
to johnny and also i think they should
just
lean into that just make robbie a bad
kid make him the bad guy make him a
villain
and just make it happen because robbie
being this
fringe good guy maybe he's good it's
like he's not interesting enough for
that just
make him a bad guy john crease can be
like yeah johnny he's who you could have
been by my side he's the full potential
of your bloodline you know
all those speeches because they're
fighting for the soul of the most
important place on earth
the valley so in the end it's another
great season for cobra kai what can i
say it's ridiculous when it wants to be
fun
it's heartfelt enough for you to take in
the lessons because it's not
so ridiculous you're like it has nothing
to say if they overcook the cheese it
would be a guilty pleasure watch and i'd
still say i enjoy it at a guilty
pleasure level but it's
not it's it's just really good
entertainment and i for one love
johnny's character next season they're
bringing in terry silver
because of the flashbacks she turns over
you see this one dude you're like
you are terry silver for sure you got
the hair you got the grin
and then the guy dies you're like oh i
guess you're not and it was the other
guy that was terry silver but you know
that guy auditioned to be terry silver
and i guess they were like you're so
perfect
i think we're gonna fool the audience
and then have you killed because you're
so perfect for young terry's over the
point is next season they're bringing
him in i do get a bit of concern
because that's more of a daniel
storyline than johnny because
johnny doesn't even know who terry
silver is but daniel has that history
with terry silver so
bringing him in i feel like that's it's
going to be more daniel screen time
not that i hate ralph macchio or
anything but i just feel like
cobra kai johnny's story is what i
signed up for
it's what's kept me engaged he's the
character i love most in it so if you're
gonna give daniel more screen time again
next season just don't cut johnny out
too much
keep him the focal point the center of
attention because it is his show
and i hope they remember that all right
so cobra kai's season three have you
seen it what did you think about it how
did the seasons rank for you i don't
even know how i'd rank them that's kind
of a [ __ ] thing to ask you how to rank
them and i don't even know how i'd rank
them but whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
wait no how does john crease do it
[Music]
you